よろしくお願いします
えーと あの いろいろあの
俗世間では皆様の人生の中ではね
興味あるだろうというテーマについても
随分一人我々は勝手に妄想して妄想して
まあいろいろテーマ作ったりはするんですけど
当然こちら勝手に決めるテーマだからね
もう100%受けないという結果もあるし
まあ興味ないというよね
うーん まあそれはそれで大変ありがたい結果なんですけど
あの もし皆様にも あの
こういうことはどうでしょうか
こういう問題をあなた方はどう説明するのかどうかね
そういう皆様方が知りたい
俗世間のことなんですね
自分のこと あるいは自分の家族周りのこと
あるいは世間のこと そんなのは仏教はどう見ているのかというような疑問とかね
出していただければ えーと
結構このこういう内容とか
作る方々にとっては大変助かると思います
うーん まあ大変な協力になります
そういうわけで 皆様にあの
俗世間のあらゆる もう日々世界が変わってますけどね
知ってますかね おそらく知らないでしょう
世界っていうのは日々変わっているんです
暇がなくて世界に行っていくことはできませんですか？というかもしれませんだけど
だいたい世界っていうのは毎日変わっていくんだから
人間の興味っていうのもだいたい毎日変わっていきますね
うーん  そういうことについて
まあ古臭い仏教はどういう風に反応するのかというね
ということなんですけど
ですから この皆様に聞きたい質問
疑問があったら どうぞあの
連絡してみてください
そういうのは返事はしません
まず だから心配する必要はないんです
で そういう質問の中身から講演のテーマを作るんです
個人的な質問を答えて欲しい方々はね
メール送っちゃえばそれには返事書きますけどね
まあこういうふうに あの
一応あの 毎月の講演はやってますけど
あの まあ何年も経ってますけどね
で 皆様の要求 要望に合わせてこれやろうかなという計画なんですけど
未だに一人も このことはどうでしょうかというね
出されたことはないんです
これはまあ 講演の内容からもう判断してみると
まあそれは当然な結果だと思いますけどね
質問出したって意味がないんだよと
まあ今日も同じことになるかもしれませんだけど
あの この感動したというね
感動についてお話ししますけど
理屈と感情のバランス
で そこを言った途端 一般的にあの方々は考えるだろうということを
一応あの この宣伝のところに書いているんです
皆様方 そんなダサいものを考えるわけじゃないんだけど
まあ普通はあの 人間っていうのはね
まあ考えるならばこういうふうなことを考えるでしょうと
ただ理屈ばっかりで生きているとね
すごくは生き甲斐がない
つまらない人生ではないかと
感情だけで頭が悪くなっちゃうとね
まあそれはそれで大変なことではないかと
私はどのように そこはちょうどいいところで
バランスを持って 喜怒哀楽もあって
またその上に理性もあってという
もう大変ありがたい話ですけどね
一番儲かった生き方はどのようにできるのかという
もう考え方なんですけど
え しかし それは仏教に当たってみるとどういうことになるのかというね
ということは まずこの
感動と理性のバランスですからね
まあ直としては例で考えた方がいいと思いますよ
例えば感情っていうのはね
例えば漫画見たりとかね
テレビを見たりとか あるいはもう天気もいいんだから
どこかへ遊びに行きたいとかね
楽しみたいと それは感情的なところで
でも仕事もあるんだと
その自分の自分が会社で仕事をする自分の場所っていうのは
まあ倉庫で汚いところでも
何の美しさもないところだとすると
なんでこんなに天気も良くて
花も咲いていて みんな遊んでいるのに
私はこの倉庫の中でもう汚いところで
もう一日中いなくちゃいけないんでしょうかというね
それでも仕事だからしなくちゃいけないということで
そこでやっぱりどちらにするのかというね
もう世間はすごく美しい大騒ぎなの
私は仕事に行くぞと言ってね
まあそれでもう暗いところで仕事ばっかり一生やってる人も
あまりなんか暗いし 仕事をサボって遊びに行く人もこれでダメでしょうしね
だからまあ適当なバランスっていうのはね
みんな世の中で言ってますよ
適当なところでしっかり頑張って
また休みを取ってよく遊んでとかね
これが理想的な生き方ではないかと思ってはいるんですが
なかなかそういう風にバランスを整えた人生っていうのはね
そんな大変ですよ できないとやってないではなくて
やりたいのはもうみんなわかってますけどね
きちんと感情と理性のバランスを整えて
しっかり生きたいと 適当な時間だけ楽しく遊んで
それからしっかりともう仕事をしたり
勉強したり やることをしっかりやって
またそこはもう体がガタガタ
もう壊れるまでじゃなくて
しっかりそこはきっちりここまでやと終わって
それからリラックスして遊ぶとかね
なんて素晴らしい人生でしょうかね
できんでしょうね 結局はできんですよ
そううまくはいかないんです
遊びたくても遊びたくてもね
遊ぶことをやめて勉強したり
仕事をしたりしなくちゃいけない羽目になるし
勉強したい 仕事したいんだけど
周りがもう大騒ぎするわ
お祭りやるわ もうどうにもならないという
仕事にならないという
このグループと一緒にもう遊ぶしかないんだと
その代わりに徹夜して仕事しなくちゃいけないんだという大変な苦しいことにもなる
だから あんまり我々思う通りには思いいかないんですね
はい これから仏教のテーマに入ります
バランスなら何でもいいんでしょうかと
例えば 収入と出費 出費のバランスよろしいんでしょうかね
一円もない人間になっちゃいますからね
やっぱり収入の方が大きくて
出費の方が少ない方がいいでしょうね
なんでバランスいいってわけじゃないんです
しかし あの あれ 何といいますか
あの エカウンタントたちが計算する時
あれはバランスシートと言うんですね
バランスシート 日本語の単語はもう辞書は持ってきてないんです
あれはもう まあ英語のバランスシートだったら CR
DR とかありますけど
この CR  DR というのは
この まあ何でしたっけ？入るお金と出ていくお金のあれですね
あれはバランスさせるんですよ
強引に でも実際はバランスだったら会社倒産するんですよ
やっぱり黒字でないと
あれは数字間違わないようにということだと思いますけど
あの数字間違わないように
またいろいろドクトリンといっていろいろごまかしできないように
左と右はしっかりバランス取るんです
おそらく会計士っていうのは一番数学下手でしょうかなと思います
この会計学作った人々はそこまで同じことを繰り返してくれる
何ページも何ページも書いたところで
書いた本人にもわからないと
これは何やと それでごまかしできんようにと
あの作った経済学も会計学なんですけど
だからいっぱいみんな見事にごまかすんです
まあそれはそれで もう大変
もう関係ないんだけど
我々俗人から見れば やっぱり出費の方が少ない方がいいんです
私が知ってるあの もう会計の知識から見れば
やっぱり出費の方が少ない方がよろしいんです
収入の方がちょこっと大きくて
そこでバランスというのはそういうことじゃなくて
人はとにかく収入はもう最大無限大に大きくして
出費は最小にしてやりしてやろうかなと思うところは無知なんですね
例えば 1対 1 はもうダメで
収入がなくなっちゃう
ゼロだからね 貧乏だからね
1万もう 100万円儲けても
100万円も飛んでしまえばもうお金ないんだから
シャレにならない 私の収入は 1 日月 1,000万円だよと
その収入は？収入は 1,000万だよって言ったらお金ないでしょ
簡単に 観光いっぱい飲むお金がないでしょうというね
ことになりますから まあ 1対 1 はダメなんですけど
やっぱりそこはもう 2対 1 とかね
3対 2 とか そういう風にあった方がいいんだけど
人間はそれは収入は 1,000 で
出費はできれば 1 ぐらいとかね
それではね  1,000円儲かって 1円しか使わないとかね
あれ 何のために貯まるんでしょうかね
お金はね 誰かに取られるだけ
この貯金したっても自分のもにならないんです
もう貯金した時点でもう他人のものだと思ってください
自分の通帳を見て まあ他人のお金どれぐらいあるのか
あれは他人のもんなんです
でも人間ではえらいこの貯金好きですね
貯金したくてしたくて
貯金はもう悪くないんだけど
そこら辺でいくらかの理性バランスをあって行動した方がよろしいんですね
ただ 数学的に収入以降出費だったら
もうバランスはとんでもないことなんです
だからバランスが結局バランスがないことなんですよ
例えば収入は 10 だったら
出費は 7 とかね で  3 ぐらい浮いてるでしょうね
それだったら別に その際やがて他人のものになったっても悔しくはないしね
それがバランスということでしょうと思いますね
例えば健康と病のバランスは何でしょうかね
これバランスあるわけないでしょうに
もう理性的なこと言えば
もう健康は１００で病は０だった方がいいでしょうね
まあ健康６０パーセント健康で４０パーセント病気だから
私はちょうどいいんじゃないかなと
あるいは私は５０パーセント健康で５０パーセント病気で
ああ 立派にバランスを整えているんだぞと
何言ってるんでしょうかと ５０
パーセントの病気でも病気だからね
だから人間っていうのは病気は０にするために頑張ってますよ
まあ０になれないんだからといって諦めるんじゃなくて
とにかく０を目指 めがけて減らしていかなくちゃいけない
それで健康状態はもうどんどんどんどん
もう５０からもう１００に近いところまで上がっていかなくちゃいけない
無理かもしれませんだけど
その努力が必要なんですよ
１００パーセントの健康で病は０っていう人間はいるはずはないんです
いたければ幽霊になるしかないんです
だから肉体ある限りは肉体そのものは病気ですからね
で もしどなたか私には病気は何一つもないんだと
まあ０やと言ったら まあちょっと逃げた方がいいんで幽霊ですよ
まあですからバランスはね
こういう場合は成り立たないんです
それから貧困と豊かさ
これ決して一緒にならないんですね
どれぐらい貧困で どれぐらい豊かでいればと話にならないんです
やっぱり １０円でも儲かったら
その分貧困が減ってます
だからそちらのバランスを整えて
ちょうどいいところで生きている層とか調和を保つとか
それはありえないんです
そういうところのバランスというのは
まあ無茶億万長者に大金持ちに世界支配するぞと
世界の長者番付にもうずっと入っているぞと
まあ石で掘ったような感じで
もう買えないようにとか
まあそれはもうおかしくて
病気で まあ人に手を出さないで
金を借りないで 借金しないで生きていられるぐらい
収入がそれで豊かですと
万が一何か突然病気になったら
もうちょこっと貯金があるんだぞとかね
台風でも来て屋根が飛ばしたならば
もうまあまあ大丈夫ですよと
貯金があるんだから これはまあ作れますよというぐらいで
まあいろいろ時々期待しない
いろんな災害もあるし
病気になるし そういうものにもちょこっと余裕があって
まあごく普通に生きていられるぐらいだったら
豊かさであると それがバランスであると
それでその 上をむちゃくちゃむちゃくちゃ儲かると思うところはバランスを崩れてるんですね
だからバランスというのはそうやってなんか数字で決めるものじゃないんです
それはこの栄養のバランスという言葉でわかりますよ
皆様が聞いているバランスはそれだけでしょ
栄養のバランス 僕は全然聞いたことないと思いますけど
栄養のバランスっていうのは
タンパク質は 400g取るんだったら
炭水化物も 400g やと
ミネラルも全部冗談じゃないんです
そのその物質の量があるんですね
あるものは 1 日 0.2 mg で
あるものは 1 日 1.5 mg で mg ですね
炭化なんとかものだったら
カーボハイドレートだったら
まあこれぐらいのカロリーですとかね
タンパク質は 1 日これぐらいですとか
その数字がすごいバラバラなんですけど
まあそこはその通りに取ることがバランスなんですね
だからバランスというのは必要な量ということになります
そういうこの単語で 人生のバランスというのは何なのかということはわかると思います
だから  1 日何時間遊べばよろしいかとかね
1 日何時間仕事をすればよろしいかとかね
は計算できるはずなんで
それは一番計算してほしいんだけど
誰もそれは計算してないんです
で 肉体で仕事をしなくちゃいけない
肉体っていうのはすごい重いもんだから
動かすと時間かかるんです
1 日は 24時間しかないんだそうです
それだったらどれぐらいこの肉体は 22時間以内で動かせるかということは計算できるはずなんです
だからといって 1 日中もう荷物運んでもらうとかね
20時間も荷物運んでもらうとか
それはありえない 肉体は壊れる
宅急便の運転やってる若者にしても
20時間 やらせているんだからね
それって肉体としては
いくら若者といってもね
ありえないんです 特に日本の事故の多いのはトラックでしょ
大型 過労だからでしょ
アホだから下手だからじゃないんです
みんなずっとスティーブン・ビルのお嬢も
あの そちらに育った人生やってますからね
だからもうもう何でもかんでもプロなんですよ
しかし ほとんどというか
もう事故事故とニュースを聞くたびに
どこかのトラックが絡んでるんです
でない場合は 子供たちがもう誰かの車を盗んで運転したっていうぐらいのことです
それは子供たちのいたずらで
もう立派ないたずらで
それで命がなくなりますからね
で まあそれはそれで そんなに社会問題ではありませんだけど
事故はね 社会問題なんです
その場合は事故があった時とよくチェックしてください
9割ぐらい大型トラック絡んでるんです
誤りが誰の手にあるか
これ関係ないんです とにかく大型トラックは絡んでるだけ
だから 普通の乗用車に運転ミスがあっても
大型トラックの人はもうむちゃプロだからね
事故を避けることはできないわけでもないんです
それで避けようとして事故を起こす場合もありますよね
とにかく過労ですよ 一旦運転始めたら
ずっともう 12時間 とか運転しっぱなしで
これは肉体はもてませんね
ですから このそういうところで
人生のバランスというものは一番大事なんですけど
これは素晴らしいことを誰もそれは気にしない
ミネラルはどれぐらい取ればよろしいかとかね
あの 何て言いますか 食物繊維どれぐらい取ればいいんでしょうかとかね
そればっかしなんで テレビで
このキャベツは山ほど 40個ぐらいもう積み重ねて見せて
1日これぐらい食物繊維食べなくちゃいけないんですよとかね
みんなこれはもうたとえ象さんでも食えませんが
それぐらいだと あ それだったら
じゃあこれがありますよと
これはもう水いっぱいに溶かして飲めば
もう 1日の取るべき繊維の 1.5倍取れますよ
それでみんなこのタレントさんたちがびっくりしてこけちゃうんですね
で まあそういうことばっかり考えてるんであってね
まあ例えば子供にしたっても
どれぐらい時間遊べばよろしいか
どれぐらいの時間勉強すればよろしいかとかね
どれぐらい時間寝ちゃえばよろしいかとか
そういうところはちゃんと計算するべきなんです
それは計算していないんだから
感情でやっちゃうんです
みんな失敗する 仕事でもむちゃむちゃやるということは感情なんですね
昼も夜も全然もうもう気にしないで
まあ最後にそういうところは言おうと思いますから
まず仏教のところを言っておかないと
バランスとは物事をうまく調整して生きることだと思いますね
それで結論 バランスというのはバランスではなくて
均等ということではなくて
物事をうまく調整する
何のために調整するんですかね
やっぱり効率を能率を上げて幸福になるということでね
目的があって調整した方がいいんじゃないかなと
ですから バランスなら何でもいいわけじゃないんです
それからちょこっとした話に入ります
もうこれドラマですけど
設定があるんです まあさっちゃんとお母さんがね
商店街に行くんです それである程度で自由な行動をするんです
まああの時間なかったんだから
誰も誰かに演じてもらうことはできないんですけど
このシーン 1 はね さっちゃんは人形を買りたいということで
おもちゃ屋さんに行く
それでおもちゃ屋さんに行っておもちゃを買って
いわゆるね お人形を買ってちゃんと帰ってくる
お母さんのところに そこでさっちゃんのケースを分析します
人形が欲しいっていうのは感情です
それでおもちゃで売っている道は知っている
さっちゃんもその 2つも知ってるんです
人形ならおもちゃ屋で売ってるんだと
これはどちらあるかも知っている
それは理性ということなんです
さっちゃんの理性 それで理性的な行動をするんですね
それで結果は無事 大丈夫
はい それはまあ説明しなくてもわかるでしょ
このドラマは シーン次のシーンに行きます
さっちゃんは面白いものがあるかと見つけてくると言って商店街を歩くんです
お母様はまあそれ適当に遊んでくださいと言ったら
もうお母さんも買い物じゃなくても見学するんだから
行って店に入ったらね
もうなかなか出てこないんだからね
ある服は全部着てみるんだからね
で これはもうちょっと大きいし
これは長すぎ これは色は気に入らんとかね
まあ時間があれば男性の服でも着てみる可能性もありますね
まあ買い物に行ったら女性はそういうもので
で だからまあ子供はあれこれと言っちゃうと面倒くさいんだから
じゃあ遊んでくださいと
それでさっちゃんがあ
じゃあ私も何か面白いものを見つけてくるぞと言って出ていくと
どうなるのか 時間が経つと母がパニックになって商店街の放送で案内させるんです
さっちゃんが出て行ったのは行ったんだけど
なかなか帰ってこない
呼んでも呼んでももう全然見当たりもわからない
もう人がいっぱいだから
お母さんがすごいパニックになる
そこでヒステリーになって
あっちこっちさきざんだりすると
まあ商店街でもそれぞれ管理あるんだから
そこで放送までしてもらう
まあ全部みんなの間で
それで終わらない お巡りさんも呼ぶ羽目になるんです
さっちゃんは見つからないです
大変なことになったんです
まあ誘拐されたか 迷子になったか
何か事故に遭ったかも
きれさっぱりわからない
大騒ぎになってます みんな
2時間経つと もうあらゆるテレビ局から
まあこれでは 1ヶ月ぐらい食えていけるぞということで飛んでくる可能性もあります
ワイドショー作って それでどういうことかというと
面白いものを見つけるというのは感情ですね
さっちゃんの 何の理屈もそちらないでしょう
何が面白いと知らないので理性はなし
何でもいいんだから面白いものでしょ
お人形が面白いか 何かあってほしいね
凧が面白いかとかね そうではなくても
何でも面白いと言っちゃうと
もう何何を面白がるかさっぱりわからないでしょうに
そこで精神的な異常者が来て
なんか面白い冗談でも何か言ったら
もうこれは行かないとかね
言った時に あ これ面白い
このおじさんはって そこで一緒に行く可能性もあるでしょう
だからさっちゃんは感情だけ理性がなかったんです
結果として迷子になってしまったんです
もう一番危険性の低いこと
迷子 どこまで行くかわからないんでしょうね
この危険性を さっちゃんが
それで命取り命もなくなる可能性もあるでしょう
それだけのこと で ちょっとそこら辺
面白いもの見つけてくると言って出て行ったら
母親も子供も遊んでることだからね
これは全然断ることはしないしね
だから微妙にそっと微妙ではなくて
理性はゼロでした 結果はもしかすると命もなくなるということもあり得る
これはシーンの 2番目のシーンです
同じドラマの 3番目のシーン
やはりおもちゃを買いたいが
店は知らない 次のシーンで出てくるさっちゃんは私はおもちゃお人形欲しい
お人形欲しい 自分で買いますと
お母さんと喧嘩して もうお姉ちゃんだから
私が自分で買いますと
自分で買いたいと言ってますけど
店は知らないんですね
勝手に歩いて迷子になってしまう
シーン 2つ１つにしちゃったんです
編集したんです それで
まあお人形さん買いましょう
どこにあるのかなとか
あっちこっちあっちこっち見ながら勝手に歩く
勝手に歩くとまた迷子になってしまうんです
お母さんと待っている店はどこかとわからなくなっちゃうんです
なぜならば感情だけですね
理性はないんです だからお人形
人形が欲しいという感情のだけに理性あるんですよ
欲しいものは何やといえば
人形 欲しいところは感情なんですけど
そこで何でもかんでも感情じゃなくて
人形というある一つのものに決まってますから
釘付けてますから 感情は暴走はしないんです
だから感情は暴走しないんだけど
この子には理性は足らなかったんです
あっちこっちおもちゃ屋さんどこかな
おもちゃ屋さん じゃあこっち行ってみようかな
じゃああちら行ってみようかなとかね
それでまた同じ結果になる
迷子になる 人に道を尋ねながら歩く
3番目のシーンの 2番目のセクションになってくると
また同じさっちゃんなんですけど
人形を買いたいし そこで人に聞くんですよ
お人形どこに売ってるんでしょうか？とおもちゃ屋さんどこにあるんでしょうか？とか
そこら辺の人々に聞いて歩く
むちゃくちゃ聞く どうなるんですかね
結果は お人形を買って無事に戻るんです
わかんなかったらすぐ聞くんだからね
じゃあこちらあの 3軒目から左に曲がって
そこからずっと歩くと突き当りがあって
そこから右 4軒行ってからまた左に曲がって
子供はすぐ忘れちゃうでしょうね
それで子供はとにかく 3軒まで行ったら
あれ 左でしたっけ？右でした
わからなくなったところで
そこらの人に聞く おばさん
おもちゃ屋さんどこでしょうか？と
で またこちら左 右 左 右曲がっていってくれたところで
最初のセクションだけ行って
またわからなくなって
また聞けばいいでしょうに
あるいは説明するのめんどくさいんだから
じゃあ連れて行くぞ 誰か連れて行ってあげる可能性もあるし
そういうことで道を尋ねたことによって
全然危険がなく さっちゃんが無事母のところに戻るんです
賢い行動したんですね
こっちは本当はシーンあの3と4なんですけども
まあ一応縮めたんです
だから人に道を尋ねて尋ねて
自分の感情を暴走しないようにしっかりコントロールしてもらったんですね
それが理性なんです それで
結果として随分みんな喜ぶ
お母さんも喜んじゃうし
さっちゃんも喜んじゃうんです
それ ドラマが終わる それから分析に入ります
解剖学に入ります 我々が知っている感情と理性はその程度ではないでしょうか
私たちの人生も大人だからといって
さっちゃんと違うことをやっているわけじゃないんです
で 大人の頭の悪いところは
子供より賢いと思っているところなんです
子供より物事を知ってるんだぞとにか思ってるでしょうね
だからずっと子供にはけっぱんし
馬鹿にされちゃうんですよ
えーと 我々大人もあのさっちゃんがやってる同じことで生きてますよ
違うところはお人形欲しいではなくて
別な別なもの欲しいということになってるだけ
欲しい内容は変わってるんだけど
プロセスはまるっきり同じなんです
だからさっちゃん取ったあの 3つの行動の中で
我々はどんな...4つでしたけど
どんな行動をとるべきかとわかるでしょ
感情のみが大変危険であることが理解できると思います
感情だけだったら大変ですよ
さっちゃんが 2つのケースでもう命まで危ないことになっちゃったんです
感情があって理性がなくなった時に
ですから 感情っていうのは危険で危ないんです
安全性と目的に達することは理性のおかげです
それで理性で安全になるんですね
だけじゃなくて あの感情が決めた目的に達してくれるんです
達成されるんです だからありがたいでしょ
理性は だから我々人生はどこまで成功しているのかということは
この理性の程度なんですよ
感情の程度じゃないんです
では 危険性と安全性のバランスはあるんですかね
これが皆様答え出さなくちゃいけない
我々の人生はどれくらい危険で
どれぐらい安全であったらいいんでしょうかね
どうでしょうかね 理性が0だったらもう生きていられません
すぐ死んじゃいます 理性がどんどんどんどん上がると
人生は成功する割合もそれと同時に上がっていきます
では 感情と理性のバランスは何なのか
感情だけなら人を殺しちゃいます
生かしてはいけません
では バランスは これが今日のテーマのポイントなんです
あるんですかね 私は答え先に出しました
2番目のスライドから
はい  1番目のスライドで
これは病気と健康のバランスと同じなんです
病気だけだったら死ぬでしょ
健康だったら長生きするでしょ
ではバランスは？どれぐらい病気でどれぐらい健康だったら一番幸せですかね
答え決まってるでしょうに
一番幸せ 一番幸せっていうのは病気ゼロなわけでしょ
ということで バランスはないんです
感情がゼロだったら OK なんです
覚えておいてください
感情は危険なんで 殺すんで
人が 病気がゼロだったら一番幸せなんです
でも病気ゼロの人間は世の中にないんだけど
まあしかし それが自分で好き勝手にありがたく育ててる病気じゃないでしょうね
逃げていかないだけでしょうね
持病があっても楽しいわけじゃないでしょうね
ただ消えてくれない 危険性はゼロではゼロで何が悪いんですかね？だから人生に感情は危険であるというならば
危険性っていうのはゼロは悪い
大量の味噌と一緒に毒を飲んでも死なないかもしれませんが
そもそもなぜ少量でも毒を飲むんですかね
大量の味噌と一緒に 何とかさんでもね
飲んでもまあ一回では死なないですけど
サイアナイドでもね まああれはもう必ず体壊します
サイアナイドは何でしたっけ？日本
知ってる方いますか？青酸カリ
はい であれもう確実に殺すんですけど
ものすごい少量ね 大量の味噌と一緒に飲むと
でもなんで飲むんですかね
それで なんでその挑戦するんですかね
危険性イコール安全性ならどうなるでしょうか
一番最悪状態でしょう
健康は 50% 病気も 50%といえば
もう結局は病気でしょうね
何もできんだから だったら耐久性で震度 3 のビルはなんで壊すんですかね
最近そういうことあるでしょうね
建物はもう震度 このビルは 3 にも耐えられませんと
だから危険だから立ち退けと
で 壊してるでしょ 別にちょこちょこと危険性があってもいいんじゃないですかね
いいわけないんだよ だから壊すんです
震度３としか耐えられない家でもうウロウロしていたところで
もし地震が起きたら もうみんな死んじゃうし
周りにも危険でしょうし
例えばビルが倒れこって壊れたら
耐久性あるビルが隣にあっても
これはもう横からもう代物が落ちてくると壊れるでしょうに
だから危険度っていうのはどこまでということはないんです
それがあのエピソードからできる分析なんです
なのにみんな言っているのはそういうことなんです
それで 今までの話では
感情っていうのはもう純粋に危険だよと私は言ったんだけど
やっぱりそう言っても
世間は喜怒哀楽っていうのは悪くない
とかなり力強く否定する
でしょうね それは誰でも認めるんですよ
悪くないと みんな思うから正しいということになりませんよ
みんな無知だからね 大衆は
知恵のある人っていうのは少ないでしょうに
なのにみんな大衆の意見に行くんですね
無知 無知度が高ければ高いほど感情に陥るんです
理性が高ければ高いほど感情に勝つんです
喜怒哀楽は悪くないと叫ぶ人は
おバカさに満点取ったよと自慢しているのです
それだけのこと あまりそういうポイントに過ぎて
私はあまりあのこの講演の中で話したくはないんです
どうったことないんです
私は満点取ったよと自慢しています
テストはどれぐらいバカかというテストですと
だから喜怒哀楽は悪くないというのは
もうただの一般的な俗人の考え方で
すごい理性のある 知恵のある
天才的な能力がある人々の考え方じゃないんです
あのさっちゃんの例で考えてみると
感情が大変危ないということ
命がなくなるんだと では死なないで何でいるのかというと
それは理性が来てガードして守っているんだからな